madame monsieur bonsoir voici les
petites rues que nous allons développer
dans ce journal
au sud des philippines l'enlèvement d'un
journaliste allemand par des hommes
armés qui vient grossir le nombre des
otages aux mains des rebelles islamistes
malgré l'hostilité affichée du vatican
la gay pride de mines à rome une semaine
de manifestations et de festivités le
pape jean paul ii interdit à monseigneur
gaillot de participer à un colloque sur
l'homosexualité
le tour de france avec pour ce deuxième
jour entre poitiers et luna 194km
d'étape et la victoire du belge tom
steels leur tour de madonna au cinéma
après la comédie musicale évita la
chanteuse américaine aux côtés de rupert
everett dans une comédienne couple
presque parfait madonna qui parle
d'elle-même nouvelle situation de crise
sur l'île de jolo sud des philippines un
journaliste allemand je vous le dise en
titres appartenant à l'hebdomadaire der
spiegel a été enlevé aujourd'hui par des
ravisseurs qui appartiendraient au
groupe des rebelles islamistes qui
détiennent en otage les touristes
occidentaux à ce climat de tension
entretenue par la suspension des
négociations
s'ajoute le cadre de ces prêcheurs
évangélistes venus soutenir les otages
et dont on est sans nouvelles le point
avec maryse burgot
cet homme à gauche est un journaliste
allemand envoyé spécial du magazine der
spiegel à joe lo il voulait aller
interviewer les otages
le voilà ce soir otages à son tour et ce
n'est pas la première fois le 3 juin
dernier déjà il avait été enlevé pendant
quelques heures par les rebelles du
groupe abou sayyaf
avec neuf autres journal cela faisait à
peu près dix minutes que nous étions
dans la jungle
quand nous avons été attaqués par les
rebelles équipes de télévision ont été
privés de leur caméra
un peu plus tard on leur a rendu
ils ont demandé une rançon d'un million
de pesos truc équivaut à peu près à
25000 dollars moyennant 175 mille francs
les 10 journalistes furent donc relâchés
cette fois-là andreas lawrence eu de la
chance mais ce soir il semble bien qu'il
ait rejoint contre son gré les autres
otages occidentaux détenus depuis plus
de deux mois et ce n'est pas tout on est
ce soir sans nouvelles de 13
télévangéliste philippins venus de
manille
ces 13 chrétiens voulait apporter un peu
de soutien aux otages de joe lo on ne
les a plus revus
selon cet homme qui commande le groupe
abou sayyaf les télévangélistes aurait
demandé eux mêmes à rester faut répondre
les autorités philippines qui les
considèrent comme des otages
les otages dont on ne reçoit plus
d'image ces photos datent du 25 juin
dernier
les autorités philippines ont interrompu
tout contact avec les rebelles
l'impasse semble totale alors que ces
hommes et ces femmes vivaient
aujourd'hui leur soixante et onzième
jour de détention en irlande du nord le
traditionnel défilé des orangistes se
dérouler cet après midi dans un climat
de tension avec le renfort de 2000
hommes
venu soutenir les forces de police
plusieurs échauffourées ont éclaté alors
que le cortège passait près du quartier
kotalik a porta donne ces manifestants
protestant se sont vu barrer le passage
par un important dispositif de sécurité
ce défilé annuel qui marque la victoire
de guillaume d'orange sur les troupes
catholique a souvent été le théâtre de
très violents affrontements dans le
passé c'est pourquoi les autorités ont
soigneusement délimitée le parcours de
cette manifestation pour éviter de
pénétrer à l'intérieur de l'enclavé
catholique il ya un an tout juste se
produisait la tragédie du téléphérique
du pic de bure les familles se sont
retrouvés pour cet hommage à la mémoire
des victimes avec toujours ces questions
restées sans réponse
on ignore les causes exactes de
l'accident les semis n'a farber sur le
parking de la gare de départ du
téléphérique 400 personnes réunies dans
la peine sous une pluie battante les
familles les amis les collègues de
travail des vingt victimes dont les noms
sont aujourd'hui gravé sur une stèle 20
personnes qui allaient travailler à
l'observatoire du pic de bure ce matin
du 1er juillet 99 à 7h30 la cabine
glisse de son câble au sol 80 mètres
plus bas
il ne reste rien les secouristes
découvrent avec stupeur les corps
éparpillés au milieu des débris
le téléphérique à usage professionnel
n'était pas soumis aux mêmes règles que
ceux qui transportent des touristes il
avait pourtant été révisée un an
auparavant
une information judiciaire contre x pour
homicide involontaire a bien été ouverte
mais les résultats de l enquête se font
attendre
nous ferons confiance en la justice mais
nous souhaitons effectivement que le
processus judiciaire s'accélère que les
mises en examen déterminer les
responsabilités et lieu et que l'an
prochain donc en 2001 en juillet 2001
nous puissions bien avant non pas
seulement commémorer un anniversaire
mais que les responsabilités étaient
jugés et tranchée par un tribunal
les familles s'impatiente trois experts
devaient remettre leurs conclusions
cette semaine l'échéance a été repoussée
depuis l'accident
le téléphérique est à l'arrêt malgré
tout les employés de l'observatoire
continuent leur travail au pic de bure
incident qu'il est désormais accessible
qu'en hélicoptère
l'effondrement d'un pont de neige au
mont blanc à 3700 mètres d'altitude a
provoqué la mort d'un alpiniste deux
autres sont blessés l'intervention des
secours gêner un moment par les
mauvaises conditions météo a permis
l'hélitreuillage des deux randonneurs en
corse après la sphère des paillotes
l'an dernier la loi sur le littoral qui
interdit les constructions en bord de
mer devrait pas être modifiée ou plutôt
améliorée après plusieurs semaines de
consultations les premiers éléments de
réponse dès demain à matignon sur place
arnaud bouter ligier julien le maire de
sartène s'est longtemps battu pour
protéger ses trente kilomètres de côtes
la loi littoral de 1986 interdit toute
construction en bord de mer lui pense
qu'il ne faut rien changer
la beauté des sites ce passe avant le
développement économique
et c'est possible des riffs ici à la fin
plan d'occupation des sols en appliquant
les temps alors là pas de problème
et en plus il y a quand même encore ce
désintérêt privé énorme enjeu je préfère
continuer à travailler sérieusement avec
les services de l'état même s'il peut y
avoir de temps en temps quelques petits
qu'on fait à porto vecchio
la baie est aussi belle mais ici on
construit 13 lotissement des maisons
avec la vue sur la mer et pas le moindre
plan d'occupation des sols
l'état ne sanctionne pas alors les
associations de défense du littoral
pointe toutes les anomalies étaient
légales ou illégales monsieur il a été
fait dans l'illégalité sans permis de
construire et en lisière du domaine
public maritime
ça fait partie des 340 atteinte au
littoral qui n'ont pas été réglés par le
représentant de l'état en grosses
certains accusent de bétonner la côte
camille de rocca serra s'en défend et
présente le joyau de sa commune par vous
voyez que ça n'est pas la côte d'azur
c'est très vierge et pourtant dit déjà
que s'est développée mais camille de
rocca serra vu un changement de la loi
littoral et dans cette baie ces projets
sont claires alors notre souhait sur
cette zone c'est effectivement de
permettre une hôtellerie de qualité
moderne compétitive
créatrice d'emplois et de valeur ajoutée
puisse se développer
les élus favorables au changement se
fixe comme objectif de doubler la
capacité hôtelière de lille et de
bénéficier pleinement des retombées de
l'or bleu en région parisienne de
violents orages dans le val d'oise cet
après midi ont provoqué des dégâts et en
particulier l'effondrement en partie du
toit d'un mcdonald's de cinq personnes
très légèrement blessé une cinquantaine
de clients se restaurer au moment de
l'incident par ailleurs 3 400 personnes
ont été évacuées dans la zone d'herblay
où des pluies diluviennes ont bloqué des
dizaines de voitures les pompiers en
l'espace d'un peu plus d'une heure ont
effectué près de 500 sorties en vendée
un nouveau cas de vache folle dans un
troupeau qui sera très prochainement a
battu sortant de son silence le
témoignage de cet éleveur qui dit à la
fois son désarroi et sa colère françois
privat et alain darrigrand le rencontrer
chez paul vieille la colère est
intérieure et un sentiment d'injustice
domine cet éleveur de vendée va perdre
son troupeau l'abattoir pour une
cinquantaine de bêtes
l'une d'elles une vache de 6 ans a
contracté l'encéphalite spongiforme
bovine le sb le virus de la vache folle
une la responsabilité des aliments du
bétail est en cause dans la totalité des
cas on se dit paul vieille il a donné de
l'aliment empoisonné à ces animaux et ça
je sais comment je travaille que
d'autres savent comment je travaille je
ne peux pas l'accepter et c'est pour
cela que je peux aujourd'hui j'accepte
et je désire parler faire silence serait
reconnaître tout ou partie de
responsabilité que je réfute dans sa
totalité nourrit principalement sur
l'exploitation avec de l'orge et des
tourteaux de soja la vache contaminée a
effectivement consommé des farines
animales au moment de son sevrage pour
la perte de son cheptel paul touchera
treize mille francs par tête de bétail
soit 640 mille francs le prix selon lui
de son silence
on m'a demandé de faire silence avec des
prétextes de d'ordre public
en fait et faire silence faire silence
ne pas communiquer avec des médias sous
condition que pédagogiquement le
problème soit posée faire silence c'est
infantiliser le producteur c'est
infantiliser les consommateurs les
prélèvements et des tests sur une partie
des bêtes abattues ne seront effectués
qu'après demande de l'éleveur selon paul
il devrait être systématique n'est pas
ma vache qui est folle c'est
l'agriculture qui est folle elle est
folle et les responsables en fait ne
sont pas inquiétés que l' arbitre état
chargée de la sécurité sanitaire et bien
qu'ils s'attèlent aux problèmes qu'ils
arrêtent de couvrir qu'ils arrêtent de
couvrir les marchands de fabrique de les
fabricants de farines animales que
lumière soit faite militants de la
confédération paysanne paul va déposer
une plainte contre x avec d'autres
éleveurs victimes aussi de sb dans
l'espoir de déterminer un jour une
responsabilité
après tout ces contaminations par les
farines animales à bure dans la meuse
nouvelle manifestation pour protester
contre le projet d'implantation d'un
laboratoire nucléaire ses opposants
redoutent que ce site soit transformé en
un lieu de stockage permanent par
l'andra c'est-à-dire l'organisme chargé
des déchets nucléaires en france et ce
d'autant plus qu'à laboratoire
souterrain existe déjà molle en belgique
et les questions que pose un stockage
dans l'argile sont encore nombreuses
louis carzou frédéric faure une cage
digne des mille mme quelques minutes de
descente rythmée par les néons
et vous voici à 225 m de profondeur au
coeur du laboratoire de mol le plus
ancien site d'expérimentation nucléaire
en sous-sol depuis 20 ans quelque 70
scientifiques pesticides en 100 mètres
de galeries les réactions de l'argile
pour l'éventuel stockage de déchets
radioactifs a voulu tester ici c'était
possible de construire est une ado petit
diamètre à grande longueur alors ça pour
nous c'est très intéressant parce que
justement ça nous fait gagner du temps
aussi pour yb le bars président de l'
agence française chargée des déchets
nucléaires les tests effectués en
belgique sont essentielles car le site
de bure dans la meuse va lui aussi être
installés dans de l'argile idées dans ce
laboratoire de tester tous les riches ou
les caractéristiques déterminées la
réaction de l'argile à la présence de
déchets radioactifs étudier le
déplacement éventuel de la radioactivité
les expériences belges doivent répondre
à nombre de questions pas forcément
rassurante démontré que la roche dans
laquelle on dans mon souhaite envisage
de peau de déposer les déchets permet ne
transporte pas ses déchets quand les
produits
au bout d'un certain temps les
enveloppes se sont détruits car dans
l'argile qu'elles soient belges ou
françaises les conteneurs des déchets
finiront par céder
un sérieux problème qui remettent en
cause le caractère réversible d'un tel
stockage et par là même sa sécurité
les expériences menées ici en belgique
sur l'argile sont d'autant plus
précieuses pour l'andra que l' agence
française doit faire face à une autre
contrainte celle du calendrier
en effet le site de bure ne pourra
commencer à mener des tests en
profondeur qu'en 2002 et l'andra doit
rendre son avis sur le site de la meuse
en 2006 soit seulement après quatre ans
d'expérimentation à rome et malgré
l'hostilité ouverte du vatican la gay
pride de 2000 réunissant des milliers
d'homosexuels pour une semaine de fête
de colloques et de manifestations le
pape jean paul 2 qui a interdit à
monseigneur gaillot de participer comme
prévu demain à une conférence sur
l'homosexualité correspondance isabelle
steiss de nick merlin en italie elle est
un mythe
le symbole de la vraie fan et c'était là
fucino tu actrice renommée qui a donné
le coup d'envoi de la gay pride de
lumière soir aux côtés d'une autre
célébrité la transsexuelle vladimir
luxuria images d'égalité et de
solidarité dans un pays où la
manifestation provoque depuis des mois
pollinique des protestations à l'instar
dé l'église catholique
hier ce sont plusieurs centaines de
militants d'extrême droite de forza
nuova qui ont défilé à rome avec slogans
homophobes croix celtique
les saluts fascistes plus largement
c'est toute la classe politique
italienne qui a affiché au pire son
hostilité au mieux son malaise face à la
gay pride et à l'air nous italiens
vivant dans ce pays hypocrite
meego est donc cette gay pride sera
vraiment levé vie d'une nouvelle époque
nous sommes en train de faire l'histoire
comme la révolution française à l'image
de cette contre manifestation religieuse
y asseoir le vatican condamne
l'homosexualité
même s'il reconnaît l'égalité du droit
au travail ou logement et s'il existe en
pet aujourd'hui contre la gay pride
c'est que la manifestation ait jugé
blasphématoire
en cette année sainte pour les
catholiques non non non c'est celle
d'hier on ne choisit pas l'année sainte
anne et du gier vidéo les salariés ils
volent colisée ça devient évidemment une
provocation
deux cent mille personnes sont attendues
avant une samedi prochain à l'occasion
de la grande parade temps forts de la
gay pride
mais les autorités n'ont toujours pas
autorisé l'accès au colisée symbole des
martyrs chrétiens au zimbabwe une
semaine après les élections législatives
les occupations de fermes appartenant à
des blancs ont repris ce mouvement
d'occupation est le fait des vétérans de
la guerre d'indépendance largement
encouragée par le président mugabe c'est
demain que la justice devrait commencer
à statuer sur ces expropriations
massives décidées par le gouvernement
pour masquer son échec de la réforme
agraire reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux richard binet jean-françois
hoffman qui sont allés à la rencontre de
l'un de ces fermiers blancs
c'est un dur à cuire richard bedford un
de ces fermiers blancs installés depuis
trois générations au zimbabwe durant
toute la campagne électorale il a subi
menaces et intimidations il est resté
voilà ils ont planté leurs cabanes là
chez moi ils ce sont les vétérans les
hommes du président mugabe
ils nous montrent leur quartier général
et ça le fait rire
voyez c'est leur manière d'occuper le
terrain ils ont fait un petit potager
ils ont causé un cuit
ils disent qu'ils veulent notaire il n'y
a pas un chat juste leur drapeau qui
pend là-bas depuis l'indépendance celle
et bedford
rien ne semble avoir changé les
élections c'est si loin trois heures de
piste et on ne comprend pas comment
histoire a pu ainsi basculer oui je
deviens nerveux quand ils s'approchent
trop près de la maison
j'ai eu très peur j'ai été écoeurée
lorsqu'ils sont venus qu'ils ont battu
mon mari pourtant je les connais j'ai
vécu avec eux parmi nous toute ma vie
pour malin la question c'est de savoir
si le nouveau meilleur ne m'en va dire
non les vétérans nous sommes le
gouvernement que vous allez faire ce que
nous disons de fer va les laisser
continuer à être petit rond a régné en
chacun sur son territoire 5
je pense que nous allons avoir des
moments difficiles durant une ou deux
semaines
je pense qu'ils vont nous dire nous
voulons vos terres nous voulons vos
champs oui nous y tenons ici nous tenons
bon je pense qu'ils vont se calmer pour
les 4500 fermiers blancs du zimbabwe
c'est la fin d'une époque
ils savent que désormais il reste des
otages potentiel à la merci du prochain
mouvement d'humeur
du président mugabe en france les
premiers départs sur les routes des
vacances avec un premier bilan
dramatique dont nous faisions état hier
dans nos journaux 10 morts en une seule
nuit dans l'ouest de la france
essentiellement des jeunes
une situation préoccupante qui devra
amener l'état multiplié les contrôles
d'alcoolémie bien sûr mais aussi les
contrôles très spécifique pour déceler
les conducteurs sous l'effet de la
drogue
voyant comment ce fonctionne ce
dispositif à partir d'une simulation le
reportage de sophie n'est ni étiré
breton un accident comme il en survient
chaque année 8000 en france mais
aujourd'hui les simuler ses hommes de
terrain se sont mises en scène pour nous
montrer comment dans quelques jours ils
procéderont au dépistage de drogue
une procédure systématique en cas
d'accidents graves ou mortels et qui
s'ajoutera au dépistage de l'alcool le
fameux test du ballon donc le contrôle
est négatif
donc nous allons faire un dépistage de
drogue
les avants de rechercher si le
conducteur à consommer ou non de la
drogue policiers médecins me pose
quelques questions vous n'avez jamais le
chromatisme crânien le père de
connaissances à l'aide des réponses
qu'ils établissent un examen
comportemental puis clinique du
chauffard la typologie d'un certain
nombre d'accidents on avait des jeunes
conducteurs en cause avec des accidents
qui ressemblaient à des accidents alcool
mais sans découverte d'alcool nous
amener à réfléchir sur le problème des
drogues et des pistes et la drogue c'est
plutôt simple il suffit de tromper
quelques secondes ce test dans les
urines du conducteur
cat drogue sont détectés cannabis
héroïne cocaïne et amphétamines
ce test est positif à la cocaïne là
encore c'est une simulation pour
confirmer ce résultat immédiatement une
prise de sang ont été effectués et
envoyés au laboratoire de l'hôpital pour
un alice le dossier est alors transmis
au procureur preuves à l'appui
la justice va pouvoir sanctionner le
coupable il sera condamné pour homicide
involontaire mais avec une sorte de
circonstances aggravantes et cette loi
nouvelle un autre intérêt important
c'est qu'elle va permettre de chiffrer
exactement le nombre de conducteurs dans
les accidents graves qui sont sous
l'emprise de produits stupéfiants
pour le moment le dépistage systématique
de la drogue ne s'applique aux
conducteurs responsables d'accidents
graves ou mortels mais il pourrait bien
s'étendre à tous les conducteurs d'ici
quelques années
cyclisme la deuxième étape du tour de
france disputée aujourd'hui entre
poitiers et loudun 194 km remportée au
sprint par le belge tom steels de
l'équipe mapei étape sur laquelle
reviennent christelle bertrand et
frédéric basket au bout de quatre heures
46 de course
le sprint est lancé tom steels est bien
parti mais il est gêné par un coureur
télécom
le belge évite la chute de justesse et
trouve les ressources nécessaires pour
relancer la cadence et s'imposait stills
le sprinteur remportent logiquement la
deuxième étape du tour
pourtant deux hommes roues dans roues
ont voulu bouleverser cette logique
à gauche le français jacques durand à
droite eric decker les deux hommes vont
compter jusqu'à cinq minutes vendent
avance sur le reste du peloton
derrière la chasse est ouverte avec en
première ligne l'équipe cofidis david
millar le maillot jaune est bien protégé
petit à petit le peloton grignote des
secondes jusqu'à rejoindre durant et
decker échappé pendant 148 km et puis à
3 km de l'arrivée les équipes de
sprinteurs se place m'a payé telekom
dirige les débats jusqu'à ce que tom
steels et le dernier mot chez les
cofidis
la fête continue millar ne change pas de
maillot le plus possible demain le tour
arrive à nantes au bout d'une étape qui
pourrait bien se terminer comme celle
d'aujourd'hui
et parmi tous les supporteurs du tour de
france un bon jour tout particulier aux
petits geoffrey qui fait partie du
téléthon le grand prix de formule 1 cet
après midi remporté par david coulthard
sur le circuit de magny cours il s'est
imposé devant le champion du monde deux
finlandais mika qui n'a mené le
brésilien barrichello
une nouvelle performance pour le pilote
britannique qui disputait son troisième
grand prix de la saison christophe
duchiron
pour ce week-end des départs en vacances
il faisait si chaud à magny cours et pas
d'aires de repos comme sur les
autoroutes
quelque chose me disais que les pilotes
du championnat du monde se fichait
éperdument des excès de vitesse
et pour cause un départ classée rouge
par bison f1 la ferrari de schumacher
meilleur temps des essais et la plus
rapide suivie de l'autre ferrari de
rubens barrichello
l'écossais david coulthard drool en
troisième position pendant quarante
tours schumacher garder la tête et ce ne
sera pas sans difficulté allant même
jusqu'à créer un petit bouchon de
quelques secondes tant il semble évident
que derrière lui
la mclaren de coulthard des la plus
rapide une fois coulter des seuils de
passer mais ça ne passe pas et d'un
doigt vengeur de récits à plus de 100
kilomètres heure il fait savoir toute sa
colère à schumacher de le voir fermer la
porte
la deuxième fois tout en force et mon
führer coulthard a fait cette fois son
office et le voilà roulant un peu plus
vite que sur la nationale c'est du
succès au 59e tour trahi par les pneus
et le moteur de sa voiture
schumacher abandonne et perd gros dans
la sphère doublé des mclaren barrichello
3e
certes l'allemand est toujours le leader
du championnat du monde des pilotes
mais qui tarde revient douze points à
thinel à 18 il reste six grand prix à
disputer
rien n'est joué là tu rentres 39e
édition du mondial de la pétanque à
marseille près de dix mille personnes
s'y retrouve un grand succès populaire
pour cette compétition qui depuis
longtemps a largement dépassé les
frontières de la ville phocéenne un
reportage michaël darmon christophe la
roque à marseille au son de la pétanque
quatre jours de compétition pour un
tournoi qui voudraient jouer dans la
cour des grands en réunissant des
boulistes du monde entier
on vient de bruxelles d'accord vous
gagnez lancement nous aussi ah si j'ai
eu de la chance ils n'ont pu entrer dans
la compétition les autres beaucoup
d'autres au pointé devant ce stand une
grande partie de la journée
privés de leur feuille de match à cause
d'une panne informatique participants en
colère d'un côté personnalités en
roquettes de l'autre ici on ne recule
devant rien cette compétition est
surnommé le roland garros déboule avec
son petit village de gens connus qui se
produisent en jouant la pétanque jeunes
à pratiquer en privez pas de but et on
le voit tout est fait pour essayer de
rendre tendance ce jeu populaire inventé
voilà 90 ans à la ciotat par un monsieur
qui avait du mal à se déplacer
alors il a effet en eau tournier de ses
pieds à rome et à jouer dit m on
appelait ça un terme aux provençales les
pieds tan pieds dans le sable sur la
plage et c'est devenu pétanque en 1910
par jules lenoir tous les terrains de
marseille seront mobilisés jusqu'à
mercredi jour de la finale du mondial
des boules ici face à la mer loin des
plages surpeuplées la campagne
alsacienne appuyé au massif vosgien a su
exploiter la vague du tourisme vert en
plein essor et ce malgré la tempête
les premiers vacanciers arrivent dans
cette région jérôme soûlard sylvain
gauthier un arbre géraniums majestueux
le décor est planté soignés dans les
vosges alsaciennes tout est prêt depuis
longtemps pour accueillir enfin
les premiers vacanciers à ottrott
l'office de tourisme ne désemplit pas
belge française ou allemand ils viennent
de partout pour retrouver leur chemin de
randonnée il faut dire qu'on est dans le
massif du mont sainte-odile au pied du
massif alors ya à peu près une bonne
centaine de kilomètres balisés invente
les gens viennent surtout pour les
balades c'est la convivialité des
vacances pour me dire et pour trouver sa
route
suivez le point jumeaux les entraîner ou
simples amateurs
ici chacun peut marcher à son rythme à
son pas et trouver à tout moment le
temps de prendre son temps
ça veut peut être beaucoup comme belge
d'un train cet endroit là et malgré la
tempête de décembre 90 % des chemins de
randonnée reste aujourd'hui accessible
là où les arbres sont renversés
évidemment il ya des chantiers qui sont
dangereux mais tous les itinéraires sont
préservés et quand il y à une fermeture
d'itinéraires on le dvi / petite portion
de circuit sans que ça nuise au
cheminement un peu de fraîcheur dans une
cave traditionnelle du pays et une autre
découverte pour nos touristes belges à
autre aucune vins d'alsace n'est pas
forcément blanc rouge en mer rouge
d'ottrott c'est donc notre spécialité
notre particularité de la particularité
de cela c'est un pinot noir qui est fait
à ottrott qui porte donc le nom du
village et que ça fait donc dur je
trotte histoire et terroir pour une
dégustation joyeuse la simplicité
alsacienne c'est peut-être le secret
de vacances réussies et six mois après
la tempête qui a considérablement
dévasté la forêt girondine est
sévèrement touché plus de la moitié des
campings du département
les professionnels du tourisme sont
aujourd'hui prêts à accueillir les
vacanciers reportage dans le bassin
d'arcachon à la dune du pilat
jean-françois ga et vincent pacifique au
pied de la dune du pilat 500
emplacements sans doute un peu moins
ombragé que les années précédents ici
sept cent mille francs ont été investis
pour effacer les traces de la tempête du
27 décembre et accueillir normalement
les premiers tours y aller mobil-home
aussi un déplacé leur emplacement
retourner - carrément sous l'effet du
vent malgré l'on leur ancrage j'ai la
chance d'avoir un établissement qui
n'est pas défigurée et à part quelques
une petite zone qui sont plus
ensoleillés qui est que les années
passées non mes clients si vous voulez
fantôme effort de mémoire pour se
souvenir de ces événements et ne trouve
pas de changement notoire
les images de la forêt dévastée par le
vent n'ont visiblement pas découragé les
vacanciers les 162 campings du
département ainsi pu ouvrir leurs portes
on est venu nous au mois de mai en
reconnaissance des lieux pour voir où on
allait pouvoir s'installer et en
sandales en justement on est passé mais
bon ça nous a pas fait peur aujourd'hui
selon la direction départementale du
tourisme les taux de réservation sont
conformes aux résultats de l'été 99
et si certains vacanciers ont choisi le
littoral aquitain aux dépens des côtes
bretonnes souillé par l'erika
c'est une tendance qui resterait
marginale j'ai fait de la première marée
noire ça n'a rien à voir en pour
maintenant les plages sont propres à mon
avenir c'est pas ça qui m'a fait venir
dont on change de plage au chant je
crois à tous les ans six mois après la
tempête la saison estivale semble lancée
en gironde les professionnels du
tourisme pense d'ailleurs affiché
complet entre le 14 juillet et le 20
août
cet été comme chaque année environ un
million et demi de touristes sont
attendus dans le département les
traditions se perdent à londres pour la
première fois à buckingham palace une
femme m'a pris part à la fameuse relève
de la garde qui adore photographier les
touristes du jamais vu dans les
du palais royal cette sérieuse entorse
s'explique par la présence dans le
contingent australien de quatre femmes
qui ont en charge un jour sur deux jusqu
au 20 juillet cette relève de la garde
après sans doute tout rentrera dans
l'ordre cinéma avec le retour de madonna
sur les écrans après la comédie musicale
évita
voici une nouvelle facette de la
chanteuse américaine dans une comédie un
couple presque parfait où elle forma
d'où ils n'attendaient avec rupert
everett nicole cornu langlois a
rencontré cette nouvelle madonna londres
où elle est actuellement la nouvelle
madonna est arrivée à sagy épanouie par
la maternité dans sa ville mais aussi à
l'écran dans cette comédie un moment
d'égarement avec son meilleur ami et
c'est un couple de parents un solide au
comme un clip
nous allons élever l'enfant sans aubin
rosaire envers l'homosexualité elle perd
deux mois robert d'un homme sans misère
il a toujours été là c'est michael maze
ex on se mariera pas comme ça on pourra
pas divorcer beatles
je pense que si ce film est si important
pour moi c'est que la famille
aujourd'hui à toutes les formes et
toutes les tailles
c'est une façon très moderne très
contemporaine de voir la famine enfin
c'est ce que tu es un pdc caïds comme
l'a dit bon qu'est ce que c'est ces
denières sont-ils sandra c'est ensuite
qu'ils voient à l'opéra je trouve que
vos pertes everett est parfait pour ce
rôle même s'il est homosexuel beaucoup
de femmes ne trouvent très attirant ja
je comprends pas qu'un homme puisse
renoncer à toi tu es la seule femme au
monde que j'aurais aimé être
robert regarde moi c'est plus un temps
tu comprends je ne luttera autant
l'essence de la personnalité de cette
femme c'est ce mélange de force et de
faiblesse
cela me ressemble beaucoup à dire que
cette ambivalence son côté enfantin et
fort à la fois tout cela m'attire
cela fait partie de moi j'ai un rendez
vous galant quoi j'ai un rendez vous
galant
non ok ben cooper conseiller financier
new york c'est drôle et tendre à la fois
les problèmes s'aplanissent rien n'est
grave
est-ce que c'est ben papa maintenant
quoi pugh blue avez vous sacrifier
beaucoup de choses pour obtenir la
célébrité j'ai dû sacrifier beaucoup de
choses pour faire un travail pour
devenir célèbre c'est facile de devenir
célèbre des milliers de gens le sont la
semaine guy n'est pas facile c'est le
continuer son travail il y d'être
créatif être productif jacent perdre son
équilibre mental sur le long terme cela
j'ai du sexe aussi beaucoup de choses
mais vraiment cela valait la peine
le festival de montpellier fête ses 20
ans 20 ans consacrés à la danse
contemporaine sous toutes ses formes
l'occasion de faire un bilan de la danse
et de ses danseurs
l'astreinte quotidienne d'une passion
dévorante pas toujours reconnue et
appréciée à sa juste valeur celle du
talent jean jacques dufour et christian
galley montpellier danse à 20 ans 20 ans
et des lendemains plein de promesses
c'est bizarre parce que quand on regarde
comme l'impression que c'est du
plastique épais de danse contemporaine
parce que notre notre base est une base
très classique donc nous faisons
l'échauffement c'est l échauffement
toujours une classe de classiques et
mauro bigonzetti a toujours été très
inspiré par d'abord le classique il a
transformé mouvement classique à sa
manière ce qui fait que ça donne à la
fin du contemporain le danseur de la
compagnie intervalles et aussi révisé
est née au moment de l'explosion de la
danse contemporaine française
c'était il ya 25 ans depuis à force de
jouer des mains et des pieds
la discipline a fini par s'imposer au
jour d'aujourd'hui on peut dire qu'on a
fait un petit bout du chemin on n'a pas
fait tout ce chemin qu'est ce qu'ils
vont vous avez le public oui au public
heureusement d'ailleurs ses principales
mais je crois que la situation des
danseurs est encore très précaire
on se rend compte qu'il ya très peu de
débouchés au jour d'aujourd'hui pour des
danseurs qui ont entre 40 45 ans auteur
d'un film sur les 20 ans du festival de
montpellier
marie hélène rey bois précise si tout
n'est pas encore parfait un simple
regard en arrière permet quand même de
mesurer le terrain conquis
c'est intéressant à chercher parce qu'on
trouvait des documents dans 88 ont
envoyé jean paul cesso prendre le
pouvoir parce qu'en france tout va à la
musique et à la danse et danse aux
derniers mois que ce mouvement petit à
petit son d'années quand même beaucoup
de terrain jean paul c'est le directeur
de montpellier danse un directeur
heureux aujourd'hui on tourne maintenant
régulièrement me suis plusieurs années
entre eux
30000 à 40000 spectateurs intéressés
personnes intéressées par ce qu'on fait
le festival a commencé avec 5000 à 10000
on voit bien d'ailleurs on évoquer ses
souvenirs il ya pas si longtemps
quoi qu'on en pense et malgré son
immense talent les premières photos de
magouilles s'est présenté dans les
stalles ici dans cette ville entre 80 et
85 la moitié de la salle partait si
désormais les salles pour le plein les
salaires des danseurs contemporains
reste plutôt mince surtout si on les
compare avec ceux des stars de la danse
des contemporains
enfin ils gagnent gagne très peu
d'argent je dirais qu'au mieux il est à
15000 francs bruts par mois au mieux
mieux mieux
loin des joueurs de tennis ou des
sportifs qui utilisent aussi leurs corps
comme ça on est très loin je ne sais pas
aucun aucune comparaison possible
pourtant à l'aune de les ports les
danseurs mériterait sûrement un meilleur
salaire de la sueur
mais il paraît que de toute façon
l'argent
sa fin de ce journal j'en rappelle le
principal titre au sud des philippines
najo l'eau l'enlèvement d'un journaliste
allemand par des hommes armés enlèvement
qui vient grossir le nombre des otages
aux mains des rebelles islamistes tout
de suite de la météo présentée par
isabelle martinez suivi de la série
urgences à 00h30 vous retrouverez
laurence ostolaza pour le dernier
journal puis la diffusion différée de la
finale de l'euro 2000 à partir de 0
heure 55 demain matin à 7h50 dans les 4
vérités
gérard morin recevra marie george buffet
ministre de la jeunesse et des sports
puis le journal à 13h carole gaessler
rachid arhab excellente soirée à tous
sur france 2 à 20 heures vous
retrouverez bonne indiqué